it's the story
of two astronomers who make the
discovery of a lifetime that a giant
comet is gonna hit planet earth and wipe
out pretty much all life and neither one
of them are remotely prepared
for the crazy
media political social roller coaster
they're about to go on
[Music]
so
oh
i heard there's an asteroid or a comet
or something that
that you don't like the looks of
tell me about it and then tell me why
you're telling me about it you got 20
minutes
20 minutes that's you doc
go
go uh
madam president
uh
approximately
36 hours ago um phd candidate kate
dibiase here
discovered
a very large comet oh yeah good for you
i mean the oval office was very exciting
because that was meryl streep
kind of at the center of it
and then this coterie of incredible
actors around her
and it just felt like one of the
hallmark scenes of the movie and we had
like three days to shoot it that's the
best so you're not rushing you have
great actors
there's room to improvise
you're gonna get every angle
so that was great we just settled in
that oval office and just enjoyed
ourselves i think the oval office scene
it's a very three-dimensional scene as
opposed to
being on characters and talking heads
i'm just moving around the room picking
up moments of behavior moments
of intellectual curiosity moments of of
horror
meryl streep the president is looking at
kate's combat boots you're able to just
buy that one tiny glance and the one
shot of the boot you're able to tell a
whole lot about kate and also about the
president just her curiosity and
condescending nature and you can you can
tell so much in so little time so
efficiently you're breathing weird it's
it's uh it's making me uncomfortable i'm
just trying to articulate the science i
know but it's like so stressful i like
trying to like listen i don't think you
understand the gravity of the situation
i'm trying to articulate it the best i
can i don't know madam president
this comment is what we call a planet
killer that is correct adam was like
it'd be so great if we could have
something that i could actually play for
the actors early on that first piece i
called it the overture to logic and
knowledge it was a piece where there
were strings and a celesta which is kind
of a
bell-like instrument and felt almost
like stellar in that kind of a sense so
almost kind of sparkling but then there
were these sort of darker undertones but
ultimately there was a very different
feeling that the movie i think and the
music needed to have and that was this
feeling of a bombastic kind of insanity
at times you know there was this feeling
of almost like losing control and
there was also a feeling that we had to
push and push and push this feeling of
kind of anxiety when kate and randall
start off on their journey to try to
warn the world i think it's just
extremely anxiety-inducing and upsetting
um because you want to just scream
to everybody you know that this is that
this is coming and the president
tries to downplay it because she's
afraid of of the midterms you know it's
a very interesting scene because
eventually they they start to understand
the magnitude of the problem but it
doesn't tie into their political agenda
at the moment and that's something that
i think from a scientific perspective
he doesn't understand whatsoever they
keep trying to re-articulate the
probability of what's going to happen to
uh you know humanity and they keep
changing the percentage of of
probability of you know the the
apocalypse you know they're negotiating
it
so how certain is this there's 100
certainty of impact please don't say a
hundred percent can we just call it a
potentially significant event yeah yes
but it isn't potentially going to happen
it is going to happen exactly
99.78 percent to be exact oh great okay
so it's not 100 well scientists never
like to say 100
call it 70 and let's just let's move on
but it's not even close to seventy
percent you cannot go around saying to
people that there's a hundred percent
chance that they're gonna die
you know it's
nuts and we should get some of our
scientists on this you know no offense
but you're just two people that walked
in here with
dr oglethorpe dr ogilvy yeah i've been
head of planetary defense at nasa for 15
years and dr mindy is a tenured
professor of astronomy at michigan state
where miss dibiase is a doctoral
candidate good i'm sorry did you say it
did you say michigan state exactly they
have an excellent astronomy department
yes come on bro you kidding you want to
see my [ __ ] s.a.t scores okay let's
bottom line this what is this going to
cost me you know what's the ask here
president orlean is a woman who is
product of her time
and
her culture she's uh someone who can't
help being the way that she is which is
sort of horrible putting her in a room
with jonah hill who who basically would
go off the cuff and go in different
directions as an improvisational actor
was sort of awe-inspiring everyone knows
jonah's like a master improviser just so
comfortable can improvise all day long
so
the the most exciting moment was when i
saw oh meryl can go all day long too
and the two of them are obviously in a
lot of scenes together so that's just
been pure enjoyment economic collapse
loose nukes car
exhaust killing the atmosphere rogue ai
trout famine plague
alien invasion uh population growth hole
in the ozone jason hey read the room for
once sorry mom i honestly don't think
there's good and bad people i think
there's just wiring and circumstance
you're wired a certain way and then
you're put in certain circumstances so i
don't even think he's a bad guy i just
think there's people because of those
things that don't feel
like they need to look outside of their
existence to feel anything i'm sorry who
is she who the [ __ ] are you aren't you
or something i'm the [ __ ] chief of
staff boy with the dragon tattoo so i'm
doing fine
he worships the mother instead of the
father where some of these other people
you might be imagining like they're kind
of trying to be like the father and then
that transferred into an attraction
maybe like a weird attraction also
i can't think of another president that
i'd ever want to see in playboy how many
so he's going to try and like emulate
her she's like the hero figure so i was
like he's got to get a birkin and i had
no idea what a birken bag was and i'm
like what is it it's like well it's this
really stylized kind of like man purse
the more that jonah kept carrying the
birken bag in scenes the more it kept
making me laugh so if you see in the cut
there are actually shots where the
birken bag gets its own single you do
understand that this is an apocalyptic
event this is
this is a large celestial body heading
towards our planet
at speeds not even indeed
i hear you
i hear you
you should be proud
thank you
for taking it very seriously taking it
straight in the heart i'm so glad to
hear that i am so glad to hear them hey
uh gang obviously everything we talked
about in here super classified
right yeah
thanks for dressing up
i think what this movie is for all the
people out there who just have been
living in this crazy ecosystem that we
live in in this country and getting
bombarded with crazy screaming heads and
who kind of in a way want to laugh at
that it's ironic in this time of mass
communication where where there's been
this explosion
of
the ability of people to reach each
other that they don't whether
you know us as a species
can evolve to
truly focus on what
is ultimately the most important issue
that's ever faced humanity in the
history of civilization so it had a lot
of stakes to it and um
i just knew i needed to be a part of
this film i knew it it brought up
incredibly interesting conversation of
where we're at this particular moment in
time i think making such a difficult
thing to talk about like climate change
light-hearted and funny pointing out the
embarrassing truths in all of us it kind
of leaves this blameless place where we
can actually look at an issue and
laugh at and discuss the issue instead
of pointing fingers at each other